you're gonna find peace from going to
war with yourself whenever life will
start getting good for me God would
throw an ice anchor and stop me right
there to get over there that side
I gotta grind myself into a fine powder
I did it I did it all for sure will
wanna be happy built a life not just a
business
hey seven Carmichael and this channel
was created to help you overcome the
number one challenge that is holding you
back and lack a belief in yourself you
watch these videos because you know
there's something more inside you to you
have Michael Jordan level talent at
something so today let's live your best
believe life and learn the 40% rule that
you must start using okay let's kick it
off with learning what is the 40% rule
when your mind this is just this whole
40% rule I talk about all the time then
I made up a long time ago I started
making it up through pain tell what that
is what you go
so basically 40% rule is I am a strong
believer that we quit cuz why however
there's a 297 pounds guy right who quit
on everything is now considered when the
best man of the planet how is that
possible it means I had to change one
thing my mindset mmm so there's no way
in hell that that was it but that was
that guy was in me
mmm-hmm well that God came down here and
say hey guess what man you're a fat ass
but I will now make your badass I want a
miracle dish to be a badass no it was in
me I had to believe and make that belief
work and do hard work I did that mmm so
the 40% rule was like we have a like a
car some cars have a governor on it and
when you gets like 92 miles an hour that
car start doing this because it can't go
any faster here those cars that don't
have gutters are like it's like a fast
ass whatever Porsche whatever I'm gonna
bury it dawn we have that ability this
but we have put this governor on our
minds and you have to the factory that
put the governor on that car the
factories now you that put this on your
mind you gotta take that
until you take it off you're gonna
constantly get to 92 miles an hour and
do this cuz you grow faster yeah if I
bet you might even go slower you're
gonna find peace from going to war with
yourself could we all guess we all guys
people look at me and the reason why my
story resonates in people because I
don't hide I'll tell you exactly the guy
in I would admit to it people are great
at hiding mm-hmm so they wanted us find
peace no you got you got to take your
[ __ ] fix mirrors up in you don't just
shove it on a rug fix it and then you'll
find some peace later everybody thinks
I'm the world's toughest if I just talk
about
I broke the pull-up record I did all
these races I went to still travel with
you I was in three weeks Ranger School
if I'll talk about all the badassery
like we like doing social media and I
don't tell you that was a tough kid and
I was scared and I was depressed and
then secure and in all this what good am
I for anybody right I'm a superhero
mm-hmm I'm a liar you know I'm that now
but I wasn't born that yeah I had to
make myself into this also if you want
to have more self-love and motivation
check out my 254 series they're free the
link to join on the description below
it's about what you're saying to
yourself but it also comes at work so
whenever I was getting beat down
physically mentally spiritually whatever
I was going through just saying you know
I would put you know you can't hurt me
you can do you can outwork anybody how
badass they are everything I didn't want
to do is what got me to where I'm at
today now let's learn how to escape your
comfort zone whenever life will start
getting good for me God would throw an
ice anchor and stop me right there so
I'm going through pararescue training
and there's this evolution called water
confidence and water confidence is
pretty much what gets people kicked on
special you know Special Forces Special
Operations is the water and they try to
drown you pretty much this was not in
the warning order so I didn't know
anything about water confidence
long story short what it is is they put
16 pound weight belts on you whatever
they can do to make you uncomfortable in
the water
so for six weeks of a 10-week program I
became very uncomfortable we got down to
about 25 30 guys left I was one of them
and getting near graduation this program
thinking my god I'm about to get through
this
barely though water confidence is
killing me right they took me to medical
they they they drew my blood and
realized I have sickle cell yeah so
sickle cells of blood disease and some
african-americans have it which is not
good
no so they took me out training for a
week and when you go from being
uncomfortable that's your lifestyle you
get used to being uncomfortable right
when you go back to being comfortable
your mind says I don't want to go back
to being uncomfortable again that's
right sounds like I don't want to go
back to the water so my whole mindset
was I want to get out of this training
so I was hoping that they're gonna
medically disqualify me from a rescue
program that didn't happen a week later
the doc called me in the office said hey
guess what man we're gonna put you back
in the training I was like okay well I
missed a week I got about two and a half
weeks left I can do this I went back to
the you know to the CEO the commanding
officer he said hey guess what we're
gonna start you back from day one and
when he said that to me my mind went
back to the old David Goggin so I
thought I'd changed yeah lordy and learn
how to swim learn how to read and write
all I was doing was attacking the
surface I wasn't getting down into the
dungeon of what was really bothering me
so whatever like tough times would
happen you know any tough time that
really tough time that happened I would
go back to the sewer of my mind so this
happened I went back to Lyon I said hey
you know what Co this guy do you know
the doc didn't know about sickle-cell he
didn't give me a good reason why it's
not about sudden death heart attacks
stroke I'm not comfortable so he gave me
a medical from pair rescue so he allowed
me to leave but I really quit I didn't
want to go back in the water again right
and that's when I went from weighing 175
pounds to 297 in about three and a half
years Wow
so I did a job called tak P yeah control
and fast movers behind enemy lines but
that job wasn't a job that I wanted and
the spiral of depression you know of
trying to find things that I was
comfortable doing
whenever you find things that you're
comfortable doing you're going away from
the journey of life and I was going so
far away from my journey that my weight
showed my whole mindset now I have a
special bonus clip from David on how to
grind yourself to greatness that I think
you're gonna enjoy but before that it's
time for the three-point landing
question let's go from just watching a
video to taking action here we go
question number one how are you going to
apply the 40 percent rule in your life
number two how can you start immediately
to start building momentum and number
three where do you need to escape your
comfort zone and if you made it this far
any video you're still watching I want
to celebrate you give me a hash tag
believe in the comments as well so I got
the VFW ward for the for the Americanism
award for military service and giving
back I'm as human as human can be that's
why what you see is what you get at that
moment when I was giving my speech and I
thank my uncle for being there and I got
to my mom it wasn't just about her it
was I I know what she went through I
know what I went through and we got
knocked down so much I had a moment in
front of all these great American heroes
where I had a chance it was like so fast
it went through me like like lightening
of I can't believe I'm here I can't
believe I'm getting the award like this
that that kid who was in the fetal
position the majority of his life and so
much the fact that my body my hip
flexors are tight to this day that even
though I was standing erect my mind was
in the fetal position and when I looked
out amongst all those people it was a
sense of pride that I can't even I can't
even explain it's the moments of three
hell weeks it's the moments of in that
room by myself studying for hours and
hours and hours trying to catch up with
all the kids who are above me
yeah it's just those moments like the
real raw moments of life that was like
boom hit me and were gone but I was like
I did that over Camus you know it's like
it's his power behind the leash and
that's the feeling I was looking for in
my life I found he wasn't money went
Fame wasn't awards it it was that
feeling ever right now they feel I'm
about to break down but it's not of like
oh my god I'm upset it's like I worked
myself so hard that I turned a person
this up into this man right here not off
of reading the book off a theorist off
of going to work on myself and saying I
don't know how to do this but I know
that to get over their left side
I gotta grind myself into a fine powder
and I did it I did it all for sure will
and very few people will know how that
feels very few if you want David Goggins
top 50 rule success check out the video
right there next to me I think you'll
enjoy it continue to believe and I'll
see you there it's so easy to be great
nowadays because everybody else's most
people are weak the whole thing about
comfort zones is if you live in one for
too long